[Música]
y en revista de prensa nos acompaña
nuestra compañera Rosa Pérez más deu
Rosa Buenos días para usted Buenos días
María Clara Bueno vamos a hablar de la
que es sin duda la noticia internacional
de varios medios de comunicación se
trata de la investigación llamada Story
Killers que está realizada por una
treintena de medios de comunicación
coordinados por la organización Stories
de qué se trata esto primero María clase
te parece recordemos que es tories que
es una organización francesa sin ánimo
de lucro de lucro que tiene como
objetivo terminar no continuar el
trabajo de periodistas que han sido
asesinados amenazados o encarcelados en
este caso la investigación que ha durado
unos ocho meses se centra en el trabajo
bueno se inspira en el trabajo de la
periodista India Gabriel quien fue
asesinada en 2017 actualmente se está
llevando a cabo el juicio y hay unas 17
personas acusadas de su muerte
relacionadas con grupos
horas antes de ser asesinada lancage
había estado dando los toques finales a
un artículo sobre cómo las llamadas
fábricas de mentiras en línea estaban
difundiendo desinformación en la India
no en la línea final del artículo que se
publicó después de su muerte se escribió
quiero saludar a todos aquellos que
exponen noticias falsas Ojalá hubiera
más de ellos y en esto se centra
Entonces esta investigación
internacional en desenmascarar a un
equipo que vende servicios de noticias
falsas y tal como usted lo dice ese
equipo es el team Jorge Pues la
desinformación no solo se vendía en
India sino que ellos son un grupo
israelí y comenzaron vendiendo servicios
internacionales para influenciar las
campañas que dice de Guardián al
respecto como lo dices este equipo se
llama Team equipo Jorge porque Jorge es
el alias de el líder de este equipo cuyo
nombre real es tal anana bien
un equipo de tres periodistas
infiltrados de radio France arex y de
marker se pusieron en contacto con Ana
fingiendo ser consultores que trabajaban
en nombre de un país africano
políticamente inestable que quería ayuda
para retrasar unas elecciones bien
consiguieron a la información sobre cómo
trabaja este equipo israelí a través de
videollamadas e incluso una reunión en
persona en la oficina digamos oculta de
este equipo A las afueras de tel aviv en
esta reunión Jorge no talanan les
aseguro hemos completado 33 campañas a
nivel presidencial de influencia en
campañas electorales no presidenciales
27 de las cuales fueron exitosas explica
de Guardian así como los otros medios de
comunicación que no han podido verificar
exactamente esta información y que
quizás será un poco exagerada como
reclamo publicitario no En todo caso lo
que sí que está claro es que han
intervenido en África sobre todo
particularmente encontramos los ejemplos
de Nigeria y Kenia y que cobra entre
unos seis millones y unos 15 millones de
euros por interferir en las elecciones
no por otro lado señalada de Guardian
que anan parece haber realizado parte de
estas operaciones a través de una
empresa israelí denominan internacional
que está registrado en un sitio web
administrado por el ministro el
Ministerio de defensa de Israel para
promover las exportaciones de defensa
sin embargo el Ministerio de defensa de
Israel no ha querido responder a las
solicitudes de comentarios por parte de
de Guardian para terminar con la parte
de de Guardian uno de los servicios
clave explica este periódico británico
es el programa informático llamado
Advance Impact media Solution O conocido
también como Ims uno de los principales
servicios que ofrece este Team Jorge que
se basa en controlar un ejército de unas
30.000 cuentas falsas que difunden o
crean opinión pública en distintas redes
sociales y precisamente el medio francés
lemont Explica cómo funciona este
software exactamente con una anécdota no
la anécdota tiene como protagonista a
hillary Taylor una influencer
estadounidense que cuenta con 2,5
millones de suscriptores en tiktok es
popular por firmarse con sus animales en
su granja de Florida bien la mañana del
29 de julio de 2022 Haley
hillary Perdón se levantó Presa del
pánico no dice limón porque empezó a
recibir cientos de mensajes de mensajes
que le daban las condolencias por la
muerte de Emmanuel un emu que ya había
estado criando durante años no dice
alrededor del mundo la noticia de la
muerte de este mu que como decíamos sea
Popular en tiktok se viralizó en
comunidades diamantes de los animales
Incluso en Eslovaquia el hashtag RIP
Emmanuel se convirtió en trending topic
no bueno Presa del pánico hillary se
levantó de su cama y vio a este muy
Emmanuel no a su emo vivito y Pues en
las afueras de su granja y enseguida
entendemos lo que pasó nos dice lemont
Lemon y sus socios se han disculpado con
la señora Taylor el rumor sobre Emanuel
fue una demostración realizada por teams
para los tres periodistas infiltrados de
este consorcio para que se hacían pasar
por potenciales clientes no increíble
este tema rosa continuamos en Francia
porque hay otro tema que está causando
especial revuelo y se trata de lo que
tiene que ver con el periodista rachid
embarque Exacto Porque otro de los
servicios del Team Jorge era el
reclutamiento de periodistas para que
difundieran informaciones falsas con
pues persiguiendo ciertos intereses no y
en el caso de este periodista Francés él
difundió unas informaciones que iban
orientadas a desacreditar las sanciones
rusas no impuestas por la Unión Europea
contra Rusia en este caso diciendo que
afectaban directamente a oligarcas que
eran clientes de la industria naval de
Mónaco y que por lo tanto esto
perjudicaba a muchos trabajadores
franceses Gracias Rosa por todo este
completo reporte sobre la noticia del
día nosotros seguimos con más aquí en
directo América